wasch mir den pelz aber mach mich nicht
nass
das grundprinzip der bund länder
verhandlungen zur bekämpfung der cholera
pandemie resultat die dritte
infektionsfälle ergießt sich über
deutschland die in den sieg mediziner
schlagen alarm und das böse wort
staatsversagen und geht immer mehr
menschen immer leichter über die lippen
die kanzlerin hat die faxen dicke der
bund übernimmt jetzt das kommando die
länder werden erfüllungsgehilfen
ausgangssperren und tests pflicht was
bringt merkels notbremse jetzt eine
phoenix runde
phoenix runde herzlich willkommen bei
uns meine gäste zunächst hier im studio
ist luisa dellert unternehmerinnen und
influenza
sie betreiben einen podcast namens luke
lehrt und sie sind mit initiatorin einer
petition die einen
untersuchungsausschuss des bundestages
zur corona politik der bundesregierung
fordert anna schneider ist bei uns
redakteurinnen für die neue zürcher
zeitung in berlin und zugeschaltet der
präsident des ifo instituts für
wirtschaftsforschung professor clemens
fuß und mein kollege frank bräutigam
rechtsexperte der ard herr fust kommt
die sogenannte bundes notbremse jetzt zu
spät also sie kommt mit sicherheit zu
spät insofern als wir im märz anfang
märz einer lage hatten in der klar war
die infektion nehmen zu und in diese
lage hinein hat man öffnungen
beschlossen ohne große absicherung durch
tests und das war der programmierte
marsch in die dritte welle und das haben
uns jetzt eingefangen sie kommt auch
deshalb zu spät weil wir ja die
osterferien hatten und da hätte ja der
gesunde menschenverstand gesagt leute
jetzt nutzen wir die osterferien um die
sozialen kontakte zu reduzieren um die
testmöglichkeiten auszubauen um
vielleicht was für die datenerhebung zu
tun
da hat die politik aber nichts getan und
ja jetzt er handelt man hier auf
bundesebene und so allzu viel passiert
dann mit dieser notbremse auch nicht
also das ist zu wenig und das ganze
kommt viel zu spät das stück war
schneider dann könnte man ja eigentlich
auch sagen besser spät als nie
ich bin da ganz anderer meinung also ich
finde nicht dass es nicht nur nicht weit
zu weit geht also zu wenig weil ich bin
das absolut zu weit geht nämlich müsste
einzelne maßnahmen am anschaut wie wir
jetzt eben gelten sollen ab einer
inzidenz von 100 euro mit dem holzhammer
quasi von bundesseite über das ganze
land gefahren wird wenn man jetzt nur
das beispiel das reizwort das ja auch
thema der sendung ist ausgangssperren
her nimmt also
es ist er riet mir ein bisschen das man
monatelang pandemie politik betreibt
quasi und dann im dreizehnten monat
glaube nichts besseres zu bieten hat als
einen komplett locker und der jeder
verhältnismäßigkeit einfach entbehrt
also vor allem diese eine maßnahme ist
die schreit zum himmel und rechtssicher
diese irritation haben sie
wahrscheinlich nicht exklusiv ab heute
kann diese novelle des
infektionsschutzgesetzes um die es jetzt
geht das ist ja auch thema dieser
sendung die ist ja immer noch umstritten
es gibt widerstand von der fdp von den
linken von der afd
und auch von einigen bundesländern darf
der bund eigentlich alles an sich ziehen
der föderalismus gehört ja wie die
gewaltenteilung und die menschenrechte
zum sogenannten unveränderlichen kern
des grundgesetzes also diese sogenannte
ewigkeitsgarantie verstößt jetzt diese
maßnahme die da geplant ist gegen den
geist unserer verfassung
nein soweit würde ich nicht gehen im
grundgesetz ist ja genau aufgeteilt in
sehr langen katalogen für was der bund
zuständig ist für was die länder und
beim inflationsschutz ist es
ausdrücklich so geregelt
wenn der bund da loslegt und zu einer
infektion swiss gesetz selbst machen
will dann darf er das dann kann er da
die länder ausbreiten und das ist ja
jetzt das neue daran also wir haben ja
bislang sie haben es vorhin angesprochen
die runde der ministerpräsidentin und
ministerpräsidenten
und da war es aber so die haben was
beschlossen und die umsetzung konnten
die länder komplett alleine machen das
war die alte rechtslage und das neue ist
ja jetzt dass in dem bundesgesetz direkt
automatisch die notbremse geregelt wird
wenn in einzelnen landkreisen eben die
inzidenz von 100 gerissen wird
das ist die neue lage und die länder um
das noch kurz zu sagen die sind
zumindest in diesem gesetzgebungsprozess
ja nicht komplett raus denn der
bundesrat auch wenn er vielleicht nicht
richtig zustimmen muss ist also ganz
blockieren kann der wird jetzt zumindest
auch einbezogen und da wird es noch
heftige diskussionen geben wirklich frau
derart halten sie denn die politik noch
für robust genug mit den problemen jetzt
fertig zu werden denn die werden ja noch
lange uns erhalten bleiben
die politik ist alternativlos und das
ist ja auch der grund weswegen wir diese
petition ins leben gerufen haben weil
wir einfach müde sind und gemerkt haben
wenn du wie sie schon gesagt 13 monaten
passiert einfach man hin und her aber
nichts damit wir aus dieser lage
rauskommen und deswegen dieser ruf nach
einem parlamentarischen
untersuchungsausschuss
schon gestern bei der sendung über armin
laschet und markus söder habe ich die
frage gestellt wie konnte es soweit
kommen die können wir heute noch mal
stellen und zwar jetzt in bezug auf die
pandemie vor einem jahr galten wir ja
noch als vorbild bei der pandemie
bekämpfung und jetzt kann man das beim
besten willen nicht mehr behaupten ja
wie konnte es soweit kommen haben sie
eine idee
sie hatte zum beispiel auf forschung
erwähnt dieses wort startzusagen spitze
im raum herum sehen nicht so weil ich
dazu sagen würde bedeuten deswegen
komplett die institutionen zu sagen
hätten haben wir nicht dass man aber von
regierungsversagen sprechen kann wenn
man sehr zornig ist und ich verstehe
menschen die zwar nicht sind doch aus
weil wie sie sagen zuerst stand
deutschland sehr gut da und dann ging im
mai sehr viel in die hose also der von
bürokratie apparat zu fressen also wenn
man sich anschaue was ihnen bei
impfungen jetzt schon nicht vorangeht
obwohl im stoff da ist also was dann
bürokratie scheitert und dass auch meine
hauptkritik eigentlich an der jetztigen
notbremse quasi also alles was jetzt
passiert ist oder dass der hauptteil ist
man fokussiert auf die inzidenz also
eine zahl die aber irgendwie losgelöst
von allen anderen nummern gibt es dann
noch also die morgen stehen wie zum
beispiel die impfquote steigt ja was ist
mit menschen geimpft sind man kann ja
die eigentlich dann schon so langsam
nicht mehr so behandeln als wären sie
nicht geimpft sie sind nicht mehr
infektiös ist übrigens noch besprechen
also dass in so punkte und sollte man
zuerst mal die sachen die man sich
vielleicht um die man sich kümmern
müsste zuerst angehen bevor man menschen
verbietet da rauszugehen nachts sind wir
vielleicht zu selbstgefällig geworden
nach diesen anfangserfolgen ja gute
frage ich glaube das hat auch ganz viel
mit der kommunikation der politiker in
einfach zu tun
die inzwischen einfach angst haben zu
kommunizieren weil sie es am anfang
nicht richtig hinbekommen haben und
eine frage bei uns was den petitionen
petition an geht es auch was zum
beispiel wurde eigentlich im politischen
sommer getan der politische sommer
bedeutet ja eigentlich immer die
politiker in haben so weit erst mal hier
in berlin nichts zu suchen nun sind in
den wahlkreisen oder vielleicht auch mal
zu hause einfach unterwegs und in diesem
politischen sommer in dem letzten nahmen
wir uns eigentlich gewünscht dass da
auch auf zb kultusminister in ebene
einfach mehr passiert das überlegt wird
was passiert eigentlich nach den
sommerferien mit den schulen und da
fragt man sich schon warum hat das nicht
stattgefunden das hat ja auch in der
zwischenzeitlich stattgefunden ganz
offensichtlich weil die schulen eine der
großen probleme sind in dem zusammenhang
herr fust haben wir vielleicht auch die
entwicklung in den letzten zwölf monaten
unterschätzt was da alles passieren
könnte sie sind ja ein befürworter einer
sogenannten noko witt regelung also
eines ganz harten starten lockdown der
daneben auch die inzidenz ziehen die
neue infektionszahlen stark absenkt
damit man den wir das virus in den griff
kriegt haben wir diese entwicklung
unterschätzt den letzten zwölf monaten
er muss aufpassen no kids heißt nicht
einfach ein starker locker und es ist
genau falsch sondern noch korrekt heißt
eine proaktive pandemie bekämpfung die
die instanzen drückt also die die
infektion auf einem niedrigen niveau
drückt und die dann öffnung ermöglicht
also seine meines erachtens die einzige
strategie die zu nachhaltigen öffnungen
und meines erachtens hat man im letzten
sommer in der tat normal weil viele
gedacht haben macht das war es jetzt
wohl mit der pandemie
man hat sich im letzten sommer
eigentlich um nichts gekümmert nicht um
die digitalisierung der schulen man hat
sich nicht um test strategien gekümmert
man hat sich nicht darum gekümmert wenn
die zahlen wieder ansteigen
sehr früh gegenzusteuern hätte man das
getan werden wir viel besser durch die
zweite und dritte welle gekommen es
hätte wirtschaftlich viel besser
ausgesehen werden viel weniger tote
gehabt man hat das aber einfach laufen
lassen und ist dann überrascht worden
und der zweiten bälle und dann hat man
sich wirklich in die dritte welle hinein
gesteuert wir müssen langsam gelernt
haben mit dieser mittel incident
strategie die wir fahren in deutschland
also nicht entschlossen gegen die
pandemie vorgehen aber auch nichts
natürlich ist nicht laufen lassen es
gibt kein land das es ausgehalten hat
das laufen zu
diese strategien funktionieren nicht die
einzige strategie die solange wir nicht
genug impfungen haben funktioniert ist
eine niedrigzinsstrategie das kann man
überall in ostasien beobachten und das
haben wir einfach nicht auf die reihe
gekriegt deshalb sind im dauer knocked
down sonst werden wir schon lange raus
also der kanzlerin ist ja jetzt
tatsächlich der kragen geplatzt da gab
es ja jede menge
bund-länder-verhandlungen und schon
wenige stunden später hat jedes land das
gemacht was ihm gerade politisch so in
den kram passte hat sich damit der
föderalismus das föderalistische prinzip
auch ein gewisser weise ad absurdum
geführt durch diese ständige verhalten
etwas zu entscheiden was man dann nach
kurzer zeit wieder vergessen hat
das hat der akzeptanz in der breiten
bevölkerung sicher nicht genutzt das
kann man schon sagen denn im prinzip
auch dass man vor dieser pandemie
dezentral handeln wollte bei infektionen
das ist ja per se nicht falsch wenn es
früher mal um die masern ging und in
einem landkreis bundesweit war etwas und
man agiert dann wirklich vor ort dann
war diese grundregel um ja schon richtig
aber die pandemie hat halt alles
geändert ist wie überall neun monaten
habe man hat gemerkt es reicht einfach
nicht diese konferenz zu machen
zumindest wird es nicht umgesetzt und ja
die kanzlerin was sagt man immer ist der
kragen geplatzt
es wurde aber auch immer vermitteln hat
die kann das ja jetzt ganz alleine
machen so war es noch nie also und wir
werden jetzt ja die regierung kann ein
gesetzesvorschlag machen aber sie muss
damit in den bundestag
das wird jetzt heftige diskussionen da
gehen die gibt es jetzt schon und das
wird auch wichtig sein glaube ich dass
man das jetzt nicht innerhalb von
stunden durch peitscht sondern wie es am
freitag auch geplant ist da expertinnen
und experten noch mal drauf gucken
lassen muss weil dieses
infektionsschutzgesetz wenn sie mal
diesen spagat 28 aufschlagen das ist
inzwischen ein wortungetüm da kann wenn
man zu schnell jetzt da was regelt da
können auch widersprüche auftreten
also ich habe heute von olaf scholz
gelesen sagte man muss da jetzt keine
doktorarbeiten schreiben sondern schnell
machen gut prüfen würde ich das schon in
dem wissen dass während der bundestag
jetzt prüft die länder weiterhin alle
möglichkeiten haben hart durchzugreifen
die alten gesetze gelten ja weiter
man muss das einfach nur machen dann
wenn man es möchte und vertreten kann so
schneider ihre position ist ja die
gegenposition zu clemens fuß also sie
sind ja für lockerungen sie halten diese
notbremse und wahrscheinlich auch große
teile der lockdown bestimmungen für
falsch aber wie sollen wir denn dann das
virus in den griff
ich bin nicht grundsätzlich dagegen also
ich glaube niemand kann bestreiten dass
wir ab und zu oder was heißt ab und zu
einen lock download also notwendig ist
wenn die zahlen versehen wie sie sind
war so wichtig wäre ist eben auf mehr
zuschauen als eben nur auf eine nummer
wie vorher schon gesagt hat und ich sehe
das auch ein bisschen anders was jetzt
dieses föderale problem angeht also ich
finde gerade in pandemie zeiten wenn man
es musste man darauf auch darauf achten
dass man wirklicher herde bekämpft und
zwar örtlich und ich glaube nicht dass
das die akzeptanz in der bevölkerung
stärkt wenn man jetzt als bund diese
diesen dass das ganze land zwar quasi
über kippt mit maßnahmen die menschen
dann auch nicht mehr nachvollziehen
können also ich glaube nicht
und ich befürchte dass das eher ein
schuss in den ofen wird und dass das
nicht unbedingt das vertrauen fördert
also dafür ist ja in einem so großen
land wie deutschland für realismus da
das muss subsidiär regelt nämlich vor
ort am besten dass die längeres
teilweise stimmt zu recht nicht machen
obwohl sie es könnten
ist ja auch noch ein beigeschmack ist
neuen regelung also das klingt so als
wird jetzt alles umgedreht und der bund
könnte alles aber das können die länder
jetzt auch schon das ist nicht machen
gut ist eine andere sache aber was die
konsequenz daraus sein wird das wird dir
mal dahingestellt lassen bewusst sieger
ihre position ist ja auf jeden fall die
sogenannten incidents werte sehr sehr
niedrig sein müssen bevor man überhaupt
daran denken kann wieder ein normales
öffentliches leben zu beginnen also ich
glaube den brief den sie da mit anderen
verfasst haben dagegen denn die inzidenz
werte unter 10
vorher kann eigentlich nicht sinnvoll
wieder geöffnet werden habe ich das
richtig verstanden
nein das formulieren wir nicht so
sondern wir sagen ja wir wollen rund um
die residenz wert aber wir sagen zum
beispiel wenn es um schulen geht es ja
ganz essenziell dass wir da öffnen
können
dann kann man vorher öffnen durch test
geschützt aber man braucht sinken der
instanzen und niedriger als heute also
man kann schulen sagen wir zb bei 50
öffnen ist auch keine exakte
wissenschaft man sollte nicht so tun als
könnte die zahl der anlagen die
wissenschaftlerin
bezahlvorgänge abgesehen davon würde ich
frau schneider zustimmen die die
inzidenz selber ist eine problematische
zahl aus vielen gründen wir sie haben
gesagt aus der nordgruppe und anderer
gruppen sagen dass auch wir haben
einfach das problem dass wir zu wenig
andere zahlen haben wir bräuchten ein
screening der bevölkerung wir müssen
überhaupt erstmal wissen mit durch
repräsentatives testen wer ist überhaupt
infiziert wie viele menschen sind
investiert das infiziert das weiß kein
mensch in deutschland und nur auf basis
besserer daten grundlage kann man dann
auch mehr indikatoren hinzuziehen das
was heute diskutiert wird auslastung von
intensivstationen oder tote das ist
alles quatsch weil das indikatoren sind
die vier wochen hinterher laufen also
ich finde es richtig
man kann er durch mehr indikatoren nur
gewinnen und wenn man mehr testet dann
steigen auch die instanzen insofern ist
die zahl schwierig man darf sie nicht
allein daran aufhängen aber ist es
natürlich eine wichtige zahl und es ist
auch klar bei einer inzidenz von 150 hat
man eigentlich nichts im griff und
leider kann man dann auch nicht mehr
allein mit tests öffnen
ich glaube die entscheidend ist aber die
botschaft und das ist auch wieder der
mangel an der notbremse wir können die
botschaft darf nicht allein sein locker
und das völlig falsch sagt auch nicht
die doku mit initiative sollen wir
müssen pro aktiv durch mehr testen durch
andere daten verfolgung gegen diese
pandemie vorgehen dann kommen wir viel
schneller mit den instanzen herunter und
dann können wir auch viel schneller
öffnen also einfach nur rumsitzen und
erwarten dass die instanzen sinken und
lockdown machen das ist unzumutbar das
ist inakzeptabel das wäre mein
hauptvorwurf an die an die notbremse ich
glaube die notbremse selbst zeigt aber
auch dass der zentralstaat ist nicht
notwendigerweise besser macht das
problem ist wir hatten vorher eigentlich
organisierte verantwortungslosigkeit die
ministerpräsidenten haben gesagt nein
das sind die anderen oder es ist dir der
bund und der bund hat gesagt nein es
sind die ministerpräsidenten ja wen soll
denn jetzt der wehrleiter zornig ist
bitte abwählen
die verantwortlichkeiten sind nicht klar
man hätte auch sagen können
lasst es jedes bundesland selbst machen
dann hätten wir zumindest vielleicht
verschiedene wege gehabt aber die
ministerpräsidenten sind eindeutig vor
der verantwortung zurückgescheut für sie
ist es bequemer sich nicht dem weder zu
stellen nicht gerade zu stehen für ihre
politik sondern die verantwortung
abzuschieben auf einen nicht näher
definierbaren
das kollektiv das ist hier das problem
ist es sicher nicht so dass der
zentralstaat alles besser macht aber
wenn wir nur verantwortungslosigkeit
haben dann kann es am ende besser sein
bei denen zentralregierung sagt okay
also in einer muss mal verantwortlich
sein und jetzt beschließen wir dinge nur
noch mal ausschließlich lockdown ist
unzureichend wir müssen viel viel mehr
tun gegen diese pandemie und das fehlt
in der sander befunde die eigentlich im
wahljahr werden ja eine bundestagswahl
und sechs landtagswahlen was macht die
politik da warum zögert sie so ja ich
finde der fußball eigentlich schon auf
den punkt gebracht ich glaube oder
mutmaßen dass da auch vieles mit den
umfragewerten einfach zusammenhängt so
und da muss man sich einfach die frage
stellen in den unterschiedlichen
bundesländern welche ministerpräsidentin
den handelnden nach umfragewerten auch
zum teil und welche wirklich danach
diese pandemie in den griff zu kriegen
und auch da hat wieder auch vieles mit
kommunikation zu tun herr fuß sagt es
strategien sind wichtig das kommt bei
den bürgern überhaupt nicht so an eine
test kampagne vom aufklärungskampagne
vom gesundheitsministerium wenn es ums
testen geht findet im moment nicht
stattgeben der impfkampagne die vom
gesundheitsministerium für viel geld
umgesetzt wird obwohl sich nicht alle
impfen lassen können und da fängt für
mich einfach schon das problem ab die
bürger in richtig abzuholen
sie sind viel im netz unterwegs der
kommunikation alles was macht die
politik eigentlich in sachen
kommunikation falsch in dieser frage
gute frage ich kann nur für mich
sprechen und tatsächlich die menschen
mit denen ich mich jeden tag unterhalte
und mit denen ich kommuniziere und es
fehlt einfach an offener und ehrlicher
kommunikation wenn ein olaf scholz vor
ein paar wochen sagt helm april haben
wir wöchentlich bis zu zehn millionen
impfdosen dann vertrauen die bürger
innen drauf und wenn das dann nicht der
fall ist dann ist man enttäuscht und ich
glaube da steckt einfach ganz viel
hinter der art und weise wie
kommuniziert wird und da frage ich mich
auch welche berater und beraterinnen
eigentlich dahinter stecken und den
politiker in
gute ratschläge mit auf den weg geben
denn meistens führen dazu dass wir als
bürger innen dann enttäuscht sind
jetzt wird es ja herr programm noch bis
wahrscheinlich ende nächster woche
dauern bis dieses infektionsschutzgesetz
durch ist es geht nicht im eilverfahren
weil die zwei-drittel-mehrheit dafür
fehlt wenn das jetzt durch gegangen ist
kann der bund dann wirklich bis in die
einzelnen kommunen hinein regieren und
ist das dann auch effektiver wenn das
sozusagen alles in einer hand ist auch
effektiver ist das wissen wir ja alle
noch nicht das ist ja auch genau das
problem reinregieren da muss man einfach
auch wissen wie dieses gesetz aufgebaut
ist vor allem zu diesem notbremse
da geht es ja darum dass der inzidenz
wert von 100 sobald er in einem
landkreis für eine gewisse zeit
überschritten wird dann wird diese
notbremse dieser ganze katalog gezogen
das richtet sich also dann schon noch
nach voraussetzungen in der region wenn
es viele landkreise oder immer mehr
landkreise geben sollte die unter die
100 rutschen dann können die länder dort
wieder alleine regieren das muss man
schon dazu wissen dieser incidents wert
dass der nicht die einzige währung sein
kann das ist auch wirklich ein
kritischer punkt in diesem gesetz denn
man muss wissen bei den bisherigen
paragrafen den möglichen einschränkungen
da stehen zum beispiel kriterien wie die
impfquote oder sehr so genannte erwert
als weitere kriterien mit drin bei der
notbremse jetzt nicht das ist so ein
beispiel dafür wo sich vielleicht
innerhalb von paragrafen auf einmal
voraussetzungen nicht ganz
zusammenpassen widersprechen
deswegen weil sie gerade das
eilverfahren ansprache berechnung ist es
glaube ich gut dass der bundestag sich
zeit nimmt und die möglichkeiten zu
reagieren ich habe schon gesagt die gibt
es ja weiter und die verantwortung um
das auch noch mal zu sagen ist bislang
ganz klar bei den länderchefs das muss
man so erklären und auch benennen
und wenn die was nicht umgesetzt haben
oder sich zurückgezogen haben dann war
das deren verantwortung politisch
natürlich wenn die kanzlerin in diesem
gremium mit sitzt ist sie auch politisch
mitverantwortlich aber für die reine
umsetzung man es allein die ministerin
nachtrag noch zum rwe das ist der wert
mit dem wie viel jemand einzelnes noch
anstecken kann uns wenn das derzeit
unter 1 bleibt dann sind auch wieder
die inzidenz und auch die zahl der
neuinfektionen bringt sich eine
ordnungspolitische frage auch auf könnte
es sein dass die länder die bundesländer
in deutschland da dauerhaft entmachtet
werden könnten dass das vielleicht
sozusagen einen stein ins rollen bringt
das ein erster schritt zu einem
zentralstaat ist das befürchten ja auch
manche in der sie so kritisch sehe das
jetzt aber es ist die zeit ich einfach
auch sehr viele folgen die auch direkt
im bürger betreffen also noch gar nicht
angesprochen haben zum beispiel auch der
rechtsschutz also wenn das natürlich das
bundesland kommt dann kann man nicht mit
seinen landes wartungs gerichten gehen
klar das heißt das
bundesverfassungsgericht mit dann
eigentlich bei fast schon nummer
verfassungsbeschwerde dort einreichen
kann was das für folgen haben wird ist
auch noch abzusehen und überhaupt ist
jetzt nur noch mal auf diese
ausgangsperre zurückzukommen
dass das zum beispiel schon von einigen
verwaltungsgerichten gekippt wurde weil
es eben nicht verhältnismäßig war
also das verstehe ich gar nicht will
muss das als bund das alles sehr
schlauen maßnahmen verkaufen kann
wohl wissend dass das eigentlich nicht
durchgehen kann ich mein gutes wird es
abzuwarten ob die opposition da wirklich
mitmacht wenn eben die fdp stellt sich
da ja aus rechtsstaatlichen gründen
verständlicherweise sehr dagegen die afg
sowieso und ich bin aber trotzdem
gespannt was sich da bis ende nächster
woche noch ein man kann an diesem
entwurf also wir kommen gleich auf das
thema nochmal zurück er fußt wenn man
sich jetzt dieses neue also diese
sogenannte novelle des
infektionsschutzgesetzes ansieht was da
beschlossen worden ist also alles über
100 gibt es dann massive beschränkungen
geschäfte müssen schließen
außengastronomie wenn es überhaupt schon
auf hatte kontakt beschränkungen gibt es
bei über 200 sogar schließung der
schulen dieses neue gesetz erleichtert
ihnen dass möglicherweise die ist ja wie
vor in ihren strategie schon skizziert
die vielleicht doch noch populärer zu
machen dass sie vielleicht doch noch
zumindest teilweise umgesetzt wird oder
ist das auch zu spät für eine no go it
strategie so wie sie sie fordern
es ist nicht zu spät für einen kowitz
strategie aber diese notbremse wird
wenig dazu beitragen
sie hält uns im landauer lockdown das
wird dir so notbremse leisten denn sie
ist kein entschlossenes herunterbringen
noch grübelt würde bedeuten wir
tüchtigen die gesundheitsämter wird
erfassen die daten früher die isolieren
infektionsfälle früher
wir öffnen die schulen nicht bei einer
inzidenz von 100 sondern deutlich
darunter
und vieles mehr also ist man müsste viel
proaktiver sein sich einfach
hinzustellen und zu sagen ja wenn es
also über 100 geht dann machen wir eben
etwas dh dauer noch dauern denn wir
werden so bei 100 bleiben was passiert
denn wenn wir unter 100 gehen dann
machen die bundesländer was immer sie
machen also der die diese bundes regel
er wird uns im dauer walk down halten
das ist die die leistungen der die
einzige hoffnung ist jetzt dass einige
bundesländer eben darüber hinaus gehen
und sagen okay nach vier monaten dauer
lockdown haben wir jetzt verstanden wenn
wir wieder öffnen wollen dann müssen wir
eine art noko wird oder control
kombiniert der name ist mir eigentlich
egal
wir brauchen aber eine
niedrigzinsstrategie das ist der einzige
weg die öffnungen zu ermöglichen
solange wir noch nicht komplett durch
geimpft sind
dass aber die der visuellen
bundesregelung trägt dazu gar nichts das
eine mittel incidents strategie die hier
in bester weise auch zementiert wird
und die wird uns im dauer noch dauern
halten die wird auch verhindern dass die
entsprechenden sektor und sich erhöhen
erholen denn selbst wenn man öffnet bei
hoher incidents können sich restaurants
und hotels nicht erholen weil die
menschen eben nicht reisen
das ist durch mindestens zehn studien
aus der ersten bälle erhärtet das liegt
eigentlich alles auf den tisch also das
ist eine sehr sehr schlechte strategie
die nichts bringt der
kanzleramtsminister helge braun hat ja
erklärt war dann zwar zum teil
zurückgenommen
bis ende mai mitte juni könnte das noch
dauern mit dem lockdown mit den
beschränkungen halten sie für zu
optimistisch der eindeutig das ist zu
optimistisch sei denn die impfung
schreiten jetzt sehr schnell voran
dann werden die instanzen runter gehen
wir müssen dann allerdings sehen dass
sinken instanzen immer noch bedeuten bei
immer mehr impfungen dass sich die
infektionsrisiken auf eine kleinere
bevölkerungsgruppe konzentrieren das
heißt eigentlich müssten dann auch die
grenzwerte runter ich gehe davon aus
dass er so bis juni im lockdown bleiben
alles hängt hier dann vom fortschritt ab
aber diese politik wird eigentlich
nichts dazu beitragen dass wir früher
herauskommen
sie wird allenfalls verhindern dass die
intensivstation tatsächlich überlastet
werden
aber ob sie selbst ob das gelingt ist
meines erachtens unklar
hört man sich über die sommerferien
gefreut jetzt kann man vielleicht hoffen
dass sie möglichst spät kommen damit
noch alle wegfahren können wollten sie
zu seinem fuß noch was sagen ja super
gern und zwar einfach das ist wirklich
traurig ist dass wir so eine runde nach
fast einem jahr immer noch sitzen müssen
dieses ganze hin und her jeden monat
noch mal neu besprechen und ich schon
gar nicht mehr wenn pressekonferenz mit
helge braun oder mit frau merkel
stattfindet gar nicht mehr groß glauben
kann was da gesagt wird und dann erst
nochmal mir danach meinungen von
experten ein pole um dann wieder zu
wissen dass es nach zwei monaten genau
eintritt dass wir nämlich noch mal
länger in dem locker bleiben und ich
kann nicht nachvollziehen
es gibt papiere wie sie schon sagen der
fuß es gibt einfach papiere sie reden
die ganze zeit sich dumm und fusselig
und ich verstehe nicht man hört ihm zu
aber es wird einfach nicht umgesetzt und
ich möchte darauf einfach antworten habe
ich versteh's nicht ich kann nicht
nachvollziehen warum das nicht umgesetzt
wird ich kann nur mutmaßen und ich bin
auch sehr emotionale zwischen bei dem
thema es muss einfach auch was mit
diesem superwahljahr zu tun haben weil
ansonsten mutige entscheidungen auf
jeden fall getroffen werden können und
müssten wir mehr kein erkenntnis sondern
ein sogenanntes umsetzungsproblem und
diese regeln über die wir da gerade
reden die gibt es eigentlich seit
november schon sind noch nicht umgesetzt
worden
lassen sie uns vielleicht noch mal einer
schneiderin schon angesprochen thema
ausgangssperren ist er offenbar das
thema an dem sich jetzt alles spaltet
das ist so eine art neuer kultur kampf
was meinen sie denn ist das sinnvoll
die sinnvoll oder ist das schön dass wir
sie haben oder ist das kompletter
blödsinn ich glaube auf der einen seite
möchte damit ja ausgedrückt werden hey
wir möchten dass
sich nicht mehr getroffen wird abends
nicht mehr zur party xy oder zur
freundin xy gegangen wird kann ich
nachvollziehen ich glaube dass die
ausgangssperre dass das jetzt eine
maßnahme ist die soll knallhart klingen
und damit so glaube ich ausgedrückt
werden ob die regierung setzt damit
jetzt was durch aber meiner meinung nach
ist es einfach nicht sinnvoll und warum
sollen jetzt nochmal bürger in bestraft
werden die den ganzen tag sowieso schon
zu hause sitzen arbeiten und abends
einfach nur mal kurz spazieren gehen
möchten jetzt wieder drin bleiben müssen
ich meine wir reden jetzt hier wir sind
wahrscheinlich alle sehr privilegiert
können auch tagsüber rausgehen aber es
gibt einfach lebensrealitäten in denen
finden depression statt in dem findet
häusliche gewalt statt und ich weiß
nicht wie man diese menschen gerade mit
gedacht wird deswegen ausgangssperren
per se halte ich für unnötig und wir
können ja auch ich mal dahin gucken
warum schulen bis zu einer inzidenz bis
200 präsenzunterricht haben und im büro
es immer noch menschen zusammensitzen
also dass diese verhältnismäßigkeiten
untereinander die verstehe ich nicht
bleiben wir das im moment bei den
ausgangssperren frank bräutigam es
gerade schon erwähnt worden das ist ja
von gerichten schon gekippt worden wie
sie das jetzt rechtlich aus in diesen in
dieser neuen infektionsschutz novelle
lässt sich das so einfach dann umsetzen
oder muss da die regierung müssen da die
behörden auch mit einer klagewelle dann
möglicherweise von dem
bundesverfassungsgericht rechnen
also das ist ein sehr kritischer punkt
ich stimme der frau schneider
ausdrücklich zu wir haben ja die eine
baustelle wer macht was diese
zuständigkeiten und jetzt sind wir so
bei den inhaltlichen fragen dieser
notbremse und da sticht die
ausgangssperre oder beschränkung ist es
ja aus meiner sicht heraus ein zentraler
punkt ist da ja was bringt die
eigentlich und da gibt es studien wie
immer die sagen die bringt was man muss
aber genau hinhören warum und welcher
begründung sagen die das der grund ist
man verhindert wenn alle zu hause
bleiben müssen kontakte
also man trifft sich nicht auf dem
großen platz oder in anderen wohnungen
aber das beispiel viel gerade schon
es kann doch wirklich gut sein dass die
gestresste mutter der gestresste vater
abends wenn er dann vielleicht um
halbzehn wirklich alles erledigt hat
sagt ich gehe jetzt mal alleine um den
block
einfach mal durch zu pusten und dass man
das verbietet das reizt die grenzen des
möglichen in sachen grundrechte wirklich
aus meiner sicht überschreitet es auch
dass da geht man wirklich zu weit denn
wir müssen uns schon bewusst machen was
seit einem jahr passiert dass die
grundrechte sehr stark eingeschränkt
werden da gibt es gute gründe für aber
zu beginn der pandemie gab es mal so
eine diskussion darf man allein auf
einer banken buch lesen und daran
erinnert mich dieses ich darf abends
nicht mehr alleine spazierengehen gerade
und ich glaube auch in sachen akzeptanz
wenn man hier jetzt überdreht dann kann
man auch einen effekt jahr produzieren
der dann vielleicht kontraproduktiv ist
kann es sein dass dieses thema
ausgangssperren wie gesagt heiß
umstritten heißt kontrovers diskutiert
möglicherweise sogar den keim des
misserfolgs in sich trägt für dieses
neue infektionsschutzgesetz genau also
ich bin leider davon aus das ist schon
irgendwie kommen wir schon allein
deswegen möchte zu groß angekündigt
wieder das irgendwie last resort
bundesregierung ist rüberkommt aber es
ist ja nicht so dass sich alle
ministerpräsidenten da einig sind also
sogar der berliner bürgermeister hat
sich dagegen ausgesprochen und nicht nur
er
also darüber wird wirklich heftiges wird
wenn es ist auch so dass dietmar bartsch
linken-fraktionschef also das werden
schon einige aus einzuwerfen haben aber
vielleicht noch etwas was ganz anderes
was der fußball schon angesprochen hat
es ist ja irgendwie es kommt mir vor wie
eine scheindebatte also diskutieren doch
ständig die ganze zeit im kreis über den
nächsten log den nächsten verbote etc
aber das worum es eben wirklich ging
damit man das alles verhindern kann also
eben stichwort wie kann man
nachvollziehen wo ausbrüche entstehen
oder wie kann man den nächsten impfstoff
vielleicht nicht das allerletzte zu
lassen oder wie kann man am standort
aufbauen wo menschen nach tatsächlich
termine kriegen solche dinge es gibt
keine konferenzen dazu gerne gipfel oder
doch es gab entschuldigung einem
impfgipfel aber ergebnislos oder ich
weiß schon gar nicht weil ich so
unbedeutend war also wir beschäftigen
uns mehr damit was eben rechtlich
möglich ist und föderal etc
als irgendwie und da bin ja wirklich war
ein fuß zu schauen was sind die punkte
die man wirklich angehen müsste und dass
das überhaupt steht gar nicht zur
debatte es kühl innerhalb dieser
diskussion
er wusste was man angehen könnte wäre ja
das thema testpflicht
da hab ich jetzt wenigstens richtig
verstanden habe in den schulen soll sie
eingeführt werden in betrieben nicht da
müssen nur die arbeitgeber ihren
mitarbeitern zweimal in der woche einen
schnelltest ermöglichen
wie ist das eigentlich alles zu
verstehen mit diesen das ist ja das
zweite große punkt in diesem
zusammenhang mit der test pflicht ist
das wirklich ein lösungsweg der hilft
aus dieser klemme herauszukommen
man kann wohl aus rechtlichen gründen
jetzt die beschäftigten nicht zwingen
sich testen zu lassen aber man kann
verordnen dass solche tests angeboten
werden und wie verordnen muss man da
eigentlich nicht weil sowieso 80 prozent
der unternehmen das schon machen
es sollten allerdings in der tat alle
unternehmen dieses test angebot machen
in dieser oder jener form
das hilft wie jede maßnahme hilft aber
tests sind natürlich auch nicht perfekt
insbesondere schnelltests jetzt gibt es
ja auch andere testmethoden die da mehr
bringen also das testen ist gut wir
müssen es halt am ende hinkriegen die
sicherheitsmaßnahmen und zwar einerseits
um soziale kontakte reduzieren
andererseits solche dinge wie tests
infektion infektionsfälle eben
herausfischen frühzeitig das müssen wir
so weit bringen wo immer das jetzt her
kommt dass die zahlen wirklich
heruntergehen die testpflicht selbst ist
gewitter nicht sagen wie gesagt weil
ihnen unternehmen sowieso schon getestet
wird und die schulen brauchen eigentlich
vor allem hilfen also vom technischen
hilfswerk oder der bundeswehr oder wir
machen immer mehr personelle hilfen
damit es auch klappt in den meisten
schulen ist ja so dass die lehrer sich
das selber hinstellen mit den kindern
und dann diese tests organisieren geht
auch ist besser als nichts aber so der
ganz große effekt wird davon nicht
ausgehen ist es schon wichtig dass
getestet wird ich glaube auch deshalb
weil die bevölkerung eben dann dieses
gefühl der ohnmacht los wird dass von
diesen lockdown ohne politiken ausgehen
also wenn es immer noch heißt wir müssen
immer nur zu machen dass da erscheint
dann die hoffnungslos während es
strategien ein früheres erfassen von
daten ja etwas aktives ist und dann
spielt eben die bevölkerung auch dass
hier etwas getan werden ich habe kein
verständnis dafür dass eben nicht mehr
personal deaktiviert wird das nicht
der technisch die technischen hilfswerk
oder wer auch immer aktiviert wird um
vor den schulen zu stehen um dort die
leute zu testen also ich glaube das ist
bei weitem nicht ausgeschöpft gehörte
schon gesagt wir brauchen überhaupt
einen streaming der bevölkerung damit
wir wissen repräsentative tests also wie
viele menschen überhaupt infiziert sind
in verschiedenen bundesländern oder
regionen also da könnte man viel mehr
organisieren und dann darüber gibt es
auch studien werden würden die
infektionszahlen sehr schnell sinken
wenn man muss mehr tun würde ab heute
kann testpflicht gibt es denn
tatsächlich rechtlich eine möglichkeit
zum beispiel leute in
dienstleistungsberufen mit kundenkontakt
zu verpflichten sich testen zu lassen
bevor sie dann ihre arbeit aufnehmen
können das ist als komplettes neuland
also das müssten die gerichte erklärt
erst klären sowie viele situation jetzt
einfach neuland sind so offen muss man
das einfach sagen ich stimme dem fuß
aber zu dass das zwang immer ein
schlechtes mittel ist und man die
anreize eben schaffen musst um eben auch
was positives über zu bringen ich finde
in dem zusammenhang ist das thema home
office noch sehr wichtig also das ist ja
nun auch ein mittel und kontakte zu
vermeiden aber trotzdem arbeit
aufrechtzuerhalten
ob da jetzt schon alle kapazitäten
ausgeschöpft sind maße ich mir nicht an
zu beurteilen aber ich kann mir schon
vorstellen dass auch da noch luft nach
oben ist wieder tag kurz einen haken hat
es pflicht für arbeitnehmer also sie ja
schon soll es wenn der arbeitgeber
verpflichtet wird seine arbeitgeber zu
testen
das wenn die das nicht machen irgendwie
er ja auch seine sorgfaltspflichten
gegenüber seinem ganzen unternehmen
verletzt also dass er dann zum beispiel
sagen könnte diese person darf das
gebäude nicht mehr betreten das könnte
man schon machen also werde daher quasi
direkt attacks pflicht also nur so viel
aus rechtlicher perspektive das ging ja
schon aber das ist jetzt das nicht so
ist noch nicht so einfach bei einem
pflegeheim ja man ja eher auf angewiesen
dass man gutes personal hat wenn man die
so vergrault also frage ich mich genau
da ist die frage eben in wie sehr sehr
kann ebene unternehmen verpflichtet
werden wenn man es einer seiner
mitarbeiter sich dagegen wehren aber ja
es wäre wohl irgendwie möglich aber am
ende muss indem man zwang ausüben
wir haben schon eine ganze reihe ja
bitte ja vielleicht nur zur frage ist
das ausgeschöpft also wir schätzen beim
ifo institut das bei etwa 56 prozent der
jobs
home office möglich wäre und dass wir im
moment über 30 prozent sind also das
potenzial ist eindeutig nicht
ausgeschöpft da kommt man sich noch mehr
machen wir haben schon eine ganze reihe
von themen jetzt angesprochen bei denen
der menschen der kampf spielt ein
weiteres thema wäre in diesem
zusammenhang auch ob es sonderrechte für
geimpfte geben soll
sie haben das vorhin auch schon
angesprochen das wäre dann sozusagen
eine exklusive teilnahme am öffentlichen
leben man könnte wieder verreisen bevor
wir jetzt nach den rechtlichen
hintergründen reden mit frankfurt ii kam
die frage an sich das auch eine frage
der gerechtigkeit gibt das neue
konflikte die einen dürfen die anderen
nicht
ja das ist eine es ist eigentlich ein
grund eine rechtliche frage sie kann sie
auch nur rechtlich beantworten denn
findet das training ganz schlimm
man kann es nicht oft genug sagen aber
grundrecht es sind eben keine
sonderrechte und wenn ich erst gamestar
mensch erwiesenermaßen nicht mehr
ansteckend bin dann stellt sich die
frage gar nicht mehr ob ich raus darf
oder mehr darf das ist einfach so also
der staat kann meine grundrechte
einschränken wenn es ein grund gibt wenn
ich eine gefahr bin für andere menschen
bin ich nicht mehr also diese ganze
diskussion wie fühlen sie schon seit
monaten
aber sie will jetzt erkannt und es
eigentlich nichts wirklich passiert in
den letzten wochen obwohl die
durchimpfungsrate steigt aber dass das
eben in diesem gesetz auch überhaupt
keinen anklang findet dass man diese
menschen ja wirklich anders behandeln
muss dass ihr der gleichheitsgrundsatz
zusagen gleiches gleich und ungleiches
ungleich zu behandeln
das fehlt mal total da drinnen also
gewartet und jetzt kommt ja auch bald im
juni oder so diese eu-weiter impfpass
hoffentlich also mit dem er dann auch
reißen können soll
das geht jetzt voran langsam aber das
sollte eine debatte jetzt echt mal
besprochen
im moment ist es ja auch eine
generationsfrage die älteren können
jetzt weil ja da sehr viele geimpft sind
und bald durch geimpft sind mit der
zweiten impfung relativ bald schon
wieder los und die jungen die noch gar
keine chance haben sich impfen zu lassen
bleiben alle zuhause sitzen ja
tatsächlich kann ich da nur so aus
meiner generation sprechen dass das
viele schon sehr ungerecht finden aber
ich glaube auch hier ist wieder uns
angesprochen die art und weise wie
darüber kommuniziert wird ganz ganz
wichtig und da kann man sich nur der
politik sondern auch den medien mit
daran die schuld geben
wie über sonderrechte gesprochen wurde
und hintertüren jetzt auf gemacht werden
wenn geimpfte wieder reisen dürfen oder
einkaufen gehen dürfen und ich glaube da
müssen wir alle an die nase fassen und
noch mal darüber nachdenken wie wir
darüber gesprochen haben und wie wir die
bürger in zukunft für dieses thema
wieder mehr sensibilisieren können
und auch die junge generation ab heute
kann wenn also geimpfte jetzt ihre
grundrechte zurückerhalten sollen weil
es gibt keinen grund mehr sie ihnen
vorzuenthalten auf der anderen seite
aber nicht geimpfte bestimmte
grundrechte nicht haben zum beispiel
kann ihnen der zutritt zu einem
restaurant verwehrt werden
wie ist das rechtlich zu bewerten diese
spezielle form da wir ja ein gespaltenes
volk sind geimpfte und nicht geimpfte ja
ich bleibe mir jetzt bei den schränken
die der staat auferlegt und da will ich
ausdrücklich unterstützen diese wortwahl
also sonderrechte sind es nicht das
wurde zwar schon sehr oft gesagt aber
man kann es gar nicht oft genug sagen
als vor entscheidung dafür oder ja als
basis waren neulich ganz wichtig dass
das lka gesagt hat aus seiner sicht ist
die ansteckungsgefahr nicht mehr sehr
hoch bis gar nicht mehr da und auf
dieser basis kann man das aus meiner
sicht glaube ich rechtlich sehr deutlich
sagen das wurde auch von frau schneider
schon angesprochen
der staat braucht einen grund wenn er so
stark in meine grundrechte eingreift und
wenn ich nicht mehr ansteckend bin dann
fällt dieser grund einfach weg so es
kommt dann ein zweiter punkt das ist die
gerechtigkeitsfrage ja wir haben dann
ungleichheit für eine gewisse zeit in
klammern denn hoffentlich steigt die
impfquote möglichst schnell aber die
haben wir so und da muss man sich dann
aber auch vielleicht selbst mal auf die
probe stellen ist es dann wirklich
wollen wir wirklich haben dass alle
gleich wenig dürfen ist das ein schöner
zustand oder kann man das verknüpft sich
das rechtliche dann auch mit
gesellschaftlichen fragen kann man
vielleicht auch sagen und das ist meine
position positionen dazu wenn jemand
früher dran ist als ich und das sind
sehr viele dann gönne ich den das von
herzen dass die früher wieder was dürfen
so der staat ich unterstütze aber auch
oder sehe auch dass in den gesetzen
aktiv vom staat diese lockerungen
nicht gemacht werden ist da werden da
die gerichte ins spiel kommen es gibt
den einen fall des altenheims in
südbaden wo es darum ging alle geimpft
alle pfleger dürfen die wieder in ihre
cafeteria mussten die heftig vor gericht
streiten haben jetzt einen vergleich
erreicht das ist so ein erster fall
bruder es jetzt losgeht am beispiel der
altenheime aber ich kann mir vorstellen
dass es dieses thema ist also keine
beschränkungen mehr für geimpfte dass
das war ja auch etwas ist wohl die
gerichte dann den start ein wenig vor
sich hertreiben werden eine nachfrage
wie ist das denn wenn ich jetzt noch
nicht geimpft bin aber negativ test habe
dann heißt das ja für mich eigentlich
dass ich die gleichen dinge tun kann wie
eine geimpfte person und wenn wenn
einfach gewährleistet ist dass diese
tests zur verfügung stehen dann kann man
ja auch damit arbeiten und das dem
bürger innen so erklären oder nicht das
ist auch ein ansatz da muss man dann
wirklich aus meiner sicht alles neuland
wie immer aber genau festlegen wie lange
attestiert mir denn ein test dass ich
nicht mehr anstecken bin also ich glaube
es hat noch einen kleinen unterschied
zur situation geimpft oder auch gelesen
aber im prinzip ist das auch eine
situation mit dem man wieder mehr
normalität rechtlich und im alltag
erreichen kann das stimmt ja jetzt ist
es ja so herr fust umfragen helfen wir
nicht nur potenziellen kanzlerkandidaten
sondern die helfen wir auch dabei die
gesellschaftliche stimmung einzuschätzen
es gibt ja nach wie vor eine mehrheit in
der bevölkerung die sagt nie ein solcher
zeitlich begrenzter lockdown wie immer
der dann aus in der ist jetzt sinnvoll
warum zieht sich denn da die politik so
und hat ja eigentlich diese sie schaut
ja immer der mehrheit aufs maul oder
soll das tun warum zieht sie sich dabei
das erfolgreich erfolgreicher lobbyismus
von einzelhandel und gastronomie oder
was steckt dahinter
ja ich glaube es ist eine mischung
lobbyismus spielt eine rolle ist es
außerdem so dass in umfragen viele
menschen oder mehrheiten auch häufig für
abstrakte dinge sind also die sagen
jetzt etwa die mehrheit sagt ja wir
müssen die instanzen herunterbringen
aber wenn es dann konkret wird und wenn
man eine umfrage machen würde wollte er
eine ausgangssperre oder wollte die
schulen schließen oder wollt ihr also
wäre wie sommers denn erreicht
da ist es vielleicht nicht mehr ganz so
klar trotzdem bin ich überzeugt dass
eine mehrheit einen kurs unterstützen
würde der wirklich aussicht auf erfolg
hat der dürfte aber eben nicht nur
bestehen in einem locken sondern er
müsste auch andere proaktive maßnahmen
beinhalten warum macht das die politik
nicht dass ich glaube ich glaube das
problem ist wer immer jetzt etwas tun
will wird auch ein risiko eingehen dass
bestimmte dinge angekündigt werden und
nicht umgesetzt werden können also wer
jetzt sagt wir testen mehr dann muss das
alles organisieren man geht also ein
risiko ein und übernimmt verantwortung
und es scheint politisch attraktiver zu
sein
sozusagen mit dem strom zu schwimmen
also selbst keine andere strategie zu
verfolgen als die große masse dann wird
man zumindest nicht abgestraft also will
ich die situation
die ziemlich traurig ist mag
aktualisieren rohrschneider kann man
sagen dass sich die politik auch ein
bisschen einen schlanken fuß macht das
ist sozusagen das ganz entscheidend auf
den rücken zb der pflege und arztberuf
dass man sagt na gut die haben jetzt
zwölf monate arbeiten die am limit gehen
auf dem zahnfleisch aber die machen das
immer noch klaglos mit und werden schon
nicht kollabieren ja mit einer auf dem
rücken der sondern auch um zum beispiel
auf dem rücken von unternehmen also wenn
man sich jetzt ebenso wie herr scholz
hinstellt und sagt wir machen uns
testberichte unternehmen es gibt aber
auch keine unterstützung dafür in frage
mich wie das kleine oder mittlere
unternehmer stemmen sollen weil
irgendwie hatte auch in die cdu
hochgerechnet dass das zehn milliarden
euro pro monat kosten sollte wenn
wirklich alle betriebe testen würden und
da sieht man schon sehr die
verantwortung ab und das klingt so als
wenn es dem bösen unternehmen den bin
ich genug testen dabei hat der staat bis
vor wenigen wochen nicht einmal
geschafft dass sich bürger selbst testen
können wenn sie denn wollen also liegt
einiges im argen und ich finden deswegen
sollte statt da echt mal bei sich selbst
anfangen also bei der sendung kam jetzt
heraus dass unsere frage im untertitel
was bringt diese notbremse jedenfalls
nicht eindeutig zu beantworten ist
alles andere wäre wahrscheinlich auch
eine überraschung gewesen ich bedanke
mich bei einer schneider bei luisa
dellert bei clemens fust und bei meinem
kollegen frank bräutigam liebe zuschauer
am morgen in der phoenix runde die
k-frage union vor der zerreißprobe
jetzt folgt phoenix der tag mit thomas
bade thema darin unter anderem us
präsident joe biden und seine
ankündigung die us-truppen aus
afghanistan zurückzuziehen pünktlich zum
zwanzigsten jahrestag von nine eleven
bleiben sie bei uns
[Musik]